et après la victoire ce fut tout de même
le foris sur les champs elysées cela
faisait six ans que les parisiens
attendaient ça noélie mésanges mathieu
et marc qui dit victoire du psg dix
supporters sur les champs elysées et ils
étaient bien là hier les supporters
parents grands noms c'est vrai à peine
une centaine mais prêts à faire la fête
six ans qu'ils attendaient ce titre les
supporters la coupe de france une
victoire certes mais les avis sont
partagés après le mac
non franchement bonne saison 2e du
championnat et 2 po et à tous ses
ministres
on n'a pas super dominé quand même
aveyron c'est le score habituel de cette
année vers une heure du matin dispersion
les 200 crs imposent leur présence la
foule se retire sans incident notable
les plus motivés vous prennent la
direction de l'hôtel de ville et joueurs
ils sont invités à dîner par le maire
bertrand delanoë
premier moment de détente après la
tension du match alors président prend
alors 26 entraîneur peut parler les
remercie que paris
paris et le pc ce soir plus que la nuit
est bien avancé il est 3 heures quand
les joueurs sortent de la mairie pour
continuer la fête dans une boîte de nuit
parisienne